you know at the
at the very least like there is some
sort of
dialogue being had now and i think that
that has never been had
right and that's and that's efficient
that's why i try to use my platform for
because at the end of the day i'm
chinese right but i was born and raised
in new york city i was born in brooklyn
i was raised in new york city but i was
also raised
in chinatown with my family you know
what i'm saying that sheltered me in a
chinese family but then when i was like
seven eight years old i went into the
system group homes
uh boys home right detention centers
wasn't no asian people there you know
what i'm saying everybody was
from everybody was black uh spanish
puerto rican
you know [ __ ] like that you know what
i'm saying so i had to
you know at a very early age i just got
thrusted into that world right right but
then at first
it was hard you know what i'm saying
because it's like i'm like a [ __ ]
unicorn
you know what i'm saying i think we said
that [ __ ] before
on the last interview on but i'm like a
unicorn in that [ __ ] like [ __ ]
and then you know i'm at the butt of
every joke because i'm the only
asian person there so everybody got a
joke everybody trying to pick on me
everybody trying to so i had to learn
how to you know i had to learn how to
you know
bridge that gap you know what i'm saying
i had to i had to fix some [ __ ] i had to
i had to assimilate to that environment
you know what i'm saying
and what i learned is you know from my
experience
you know yes i went through racist [ __ ]
people was calling me all types of
racist names all types of [ __ ] like that
but that didn't come from a place of
hate you know what i'm saying
like i said i think uh you know it's
it's been normalized that asian people
take jokes very well
right and it's you know it's it's on tv
it's on
tv shows like you know what i mean like
and like you said
that's the company you were keeping
you're probably the only asian dude
around so it was it was probably low
hanging fruit they just cracked jokes
right and i'm guilty of cracking jokes
on my asian friends
that i mean in a playful manner
obviously we joke on each other we
know we bust balls but like like i said
like i think that like
that dialogue happening has never
happened before it's never but i've been
having this dialogue you know what i'm
saying
because i'm always the only you're
always the representative
oh yeah yeah yeah and and and and people
be like yo
you know um oh you know
or whatever right like but i've been
speaking up for my
for for people that look this has been
happening yeah you've been
very speaking about this [ __ ] when in
prison
you feel me and righteous island um um
we ain't maximum we in the maximum
houses you know what i'm saying
the beacon 9a uh uh uh 7b
like like c74 [ __ ] [ __ ] going up in
smoke every day red alarms people
getting cut
hectic crazy you know what i'm saying
asian people come in here
there's not a lot of asian people in
there bro and a lot of us a lot of asian
people that pull up in them spots don't
know english
you feel me because a lot of because
because so so when they pull up in there
they get
you know they get taken advantage of you
know what i'm saying so now
when i i pull up in the spot you know
what i mean i'm not gonna say i'm the
toughest [ __ ] cause i'm far from
the toughest [ __ ] right but i
ain't gonna let nobody do nothing to me
you know what i'm saying without me
doing
like like fighting back i'm gonna defend
myself and if i can't live in the house
or we gonna go up and smoke
i'm gonna pop it off i'm gonna pop the
bottle and we out of there you know what
i'm saying and i'm not gonna live
nowhere where i can't live like
where you ain't gonna treat me like a
man you're never gonna [ __ ] me you know
i'm saying i'm not gonna sit
on the floor for nobody i'm not gonna
[ __ ] just not get on the phone
for nobody i'm not going to let
nobody no nobody give me a half a
chicken or a scoop of [ __ ] rice i'm
fighting i'm gonna bang that
[ __ ] tray all in your [ __ ]
face
and i'm gonna get jumped by 20 50 people
and we out of there you know i'm saying
but
so i did that because i learned that the
only way for me to survive in a
situation like that
is to give it up you know what i'm
saying and once i give it up then
[ __ ] gonna be like nah
you know like like you know what i'm
saying they're not gonna do it